hello doctor I am a 23 year old male
with paranoid schizophrenia
however I feel like controlling 95% of
it okay so let's say I think you mean
that you're controlling 95% of it I
desire to seek a partner but I am afraid
how to reveal it any advice on how to
approach it
Oh God Steven that's a really hard
question well look you're not under any
obligation when you first meet someone
to drown them in information about your
identity so I would say The Devil's in
the details fundamentally if you have a
relationship with someone and it's
progressing and you're being honest my
suspicions are that it will come up with
its own accord you know that you'll be
able to tell in the situation when the
right way to introduce it is you know if
if you're asking me this because you've
been in the relationship for a long time
and you haven't revealed it then I don't
know what to tell you about that because
and because I wouldn't give someone
general advice about that you know if
sorry if I if I was speaking to a client
and I had some real detailed information
about their current situation I would
sit down and help them strategize about
that ask about the person you're telling
figure out how long you've gone out with
them figure out a way that it might be
revealed that you would be comfortable
with I suspect probably what you should
do is find someone you trust to talk
about it if you're already in a
relationship and if you're not then
assume that if going into the
relationship your basic goal is honesty
that you'll handle it appropriately when
the situation comes up